[MUSIC]
The rain was pouring hard
that day in Brooklyn.
It was my first day at PS 203,
teaching extra curricular courses.
200 loud and rambunctious kiddies
run into the cafeteria and
I tried to settle them down.
But they were too excited
to begin the new year.
But one little girl
named Alicia didn't look
excited at all, in fact, she was in tears.
I walked over to Alicia and
I asked her what was wrong,
can't you see it,
she answered sobbing, it's so obvious.
It wasn't obvious to me,
so I asked her again.
My hair, Ms. Oladoyin, it's my hair.
This morning it was nice and
straight when my mom fixed it, and
as soon as I got outside in that rain,
poof, my afro came right back.
And now all the boys
are making fun of me for it.
I told Alicia her hair was beautiful,
but it didn't work.
He dismissed me with a yeah, whatever.
It's your job to say that.
I write multicultural children's books.
And when I first decided to write these
books, I did it for girls like Alicia.
I wanted them to have books I didn't have,
growing up.
Books that highlight girls
who look like her, and
have hair like hers,
because representation matters.
But in the process of creating these
books, I learned something profound.
It is a beautiful thing when
we can see ourselves in
the stories of people like us.
But it is a powerful thing
when we can see ourselves in
the stories of people unlike us.
Now I know many of us in this room
would probably consider ourselves just
a little bit older than
my target readership.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I've learned by that by exploring
diverse narratives such as the ones I
write about, we get that powerful thing.
The unique ability to unravel
the similarities that can bridge all
of our differences.
It all started in the exploratory
phase of my creative writing process.
I did extensive research on all
the cultures I wanted to write about.
I watched very long
educational documentaries.
I read very dense informative
texts on the tenets of culturally
relevant pedagogy, but it wasn't enough.
Something was missing.
Writing for
children is a funny experience, you see.
I went to PS 203 so
I could learn how they learn.
I wanted to observe how they would
engage with this kind of content.
I wanted to teach them about people and
places so
that they could be curious
about our diverse planet.
What I discovered was this.
Although I knew it was very important for
them to grow up understanding these
concepts, they didn't know that.
And they didn't have to know that.
Because when you're five,
six, seven years old,
all you want when you pick up
a book is a real good story.
And that was it.
At the core of my multicultural
educational exposure mission,
I needed to harness
the power of the story.
So I picked up my research process again.
This time, I interviewed as many people
as I could find from those cultures and
those countries.
And I just listened to their stories.
I took note of every
little detail they shared,
especially the ones their
faces lit up about.
Like when I was creating Chizelle, my
girl character from Trinidad and Tobago.
I interviewed a family of Trinidadian
immigrants and they told me about the tree
that they had in their backyard when
they were growing up in the countryside.
Which is different from the kind
of tree that you would see if you
only visit the city with all
the rest of the tourists.
And they chuckled about how they would
play with their siblings underneath that
tree and
shake it til all the coconuts fell down.
A seemingly insignificant detail at
first glance, maybe, but it is in those
details that I instantly felt connected
to someone I thought was so different.
I may not have grown up in Trinidad, but
growing up in a suburban part of Brooklyn,
also with an immigrant family,
I knew all about playing with my
siblings underneath big trees.
And it is upon those little details and
those little connections,
that I built an entire book.
And for every book I wrote, I listened
to dozens more of these stories.
And from India to Colombia, I found
myself in each of their narratives.
This enabled my writing
to go beyond any fact, or
any figure, that I could find online or
in a textbook or
even in my own personal travel
experiences to those countries.
Most of all it gave me that skill that
can be applied to anyone in this room.
I learned how to relate with
people who do not look like me,
to hear them, to understand them,
to work with them.
Maybe you're not planning on writing or
reading multi-cultural
children's books any time soon.
How can you harness the power of the story
to build your own empathy bridge?
You can start by reading a book,
any book, fact or
fiction about someone from
another part of the world.
Enter their journey as
though it were yours.
See just how different or
similar the world is from their eyes.
What I love about the power of the story
is that it's not just on the pages of
a book, it's everywhere.
We just have to recognize and
appreciate when we see it.
So maybe that means you'll finally
sit down with that classmate or
that coworker that you pass by everyday.
You exchange a routine hi,
how are you doing?
I'm fine.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You see them, sure,
but do you know their story?
Or it could be something as simple
as watching a film from a foreign
country in another language and
see how it resonates with you.
My personal favorite, Korean dramas.
I love Korean dramas.
I'm not ashamed.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Perhaps none of these concepts
are new to you.
It's no surprise in the polarized
world we live in today that there is
indeed an empathy gap across our
communities that we need to bridge.
Why aren't we bridging it?
Fear, we are afraid to move
away from what is familiar.
Think about the people you surround
yourself with all the time.
Do you constantly find yourself in
the comfort zone of a homogeneous creed,
class, color, fill in the blank.
These safe spaces are important,
but the problem is it's often
where the least growth happens.
But if we can embrace the vulnerability
that comes with sharing our stories, and
the courage needed to seek out the stories
of others, we can build empathy for
our peers.
We can shatter misconceptions, one by one.
We can better understand each other,
better understand how to serve each other.
We can heighten our awareness of
those that are right around us that
we ignore every single day.
Halfway through that
extra-curricular course at PS 203,
I laid out the final character development
of my premier collection of children's
books before my esteemed
panel of fourth graders.
One of them being Alicia.
I like her.
Alicia pointed to Akua my
Ghanaian girl character.
And she pointed emphatically.
So I was intrigued.
I asked Alisha what she
liked most about Akua.
I like her hair, Alicia responded.
It's foxy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I laughed, trying to remind Alicia of
the crying incident that happened
just a few weeks earlier.
But Alicia said she had no
recollection whatsoever.
>> [LAUGH]
>> She had just finished all about
Akua's journey from
Cape Coast to Accra and
felt especially connected to the book's
references on art and friendship.
But when I asked Alicia why she loved Akua
so much, she said something very simple.
It's because I am she and she is me.
I pressed, arguing that she had never
even heard of Ghana prior to that day.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And many of the cultural references in
that book were brand new to her.
But she insisted,
it doesn't matter Ms. Oladoyin.
I am she and she is me.
So whenever I get tempted to
revert to what is comfortable,
to those who are familiar,
I remember the words of Alicia.
I restate them to myself back to
the world, that I am they and they are me.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]